un dialecte
[Musique]
bah alors on va visiter ma cabane s'il
vous plaît il faut qu'on me dit et
pourquoi je ferais ça petit parce qu'ils
attendent et vous vous êtes aveugle et
t'inquiète pas que je peux viser d'ici
il ya deux noirs poursuivre équivalent
monsieur de [ __ ] fesman rentrée du
craj paca et nous échapper dans sa loi
voilà quand il veut quoi le vieux
schnock mais c'est un aveugle cessna
hippiques qui pendent pas qu'ils voient
pas mais il paraît qu'il peut toucher
une cible à 1 kg
et j'entends très bien aussi donc toi là
tu vas arrêter d'emmerder ce brave type
et laisser tranquille est-ce que c'est
clair les gros negro c'est une blague
mais c'est lui le negro je pourchasse
parce qu'ils s'échappent et de
l'implantation qua non non c'est pas
vrai il vous sentirez comme il peut tu
vas payer pour ce que tu es en train de
faire ton très ferme et la boudeuse on
prenait pour un con c'est ça hein
bah c'est ce qu'on va voir comment vous
appelez alors moi c'est bill et toi
vasile negro qui lui bruce mcdermott
monsieur un [ __ ] d'écossais et/ou qui
plus est je sais même pas comment j'ai
fait pour marié est petit le plus dur
c'est pas de se marier c'est de le
rester mais [ __ ] mais elle est tout
sauf roues il ya des espèces de bouli
monde sur la tête un chut c'est bon là
je me laisse me faire mon propre avis ou
pas ok mais laissez moi vous le décrire
au moins ok je t'en prie ses yeux ses
cheveux tout est noir chez lui mais
encore ils éveillent cran et il a la
force d'un buffle certains ont peur de
lui j chez d'autres c'est celle inverse
et il admire mais c'est la description
parfaite dans l'ambulance mais [ __ ]
mais c'est un [ __ ] je vous dis c'est un
[ __ ] de nerfs mais là c'est bon ton
tour est passé
c'est clair bon lors de mcdermott
pouvez vous me décrire la personne à
côté de vous s'il vous plaît la personne
vous voulez dire de l'animal le sauvage
ont dit que leur cerveau est inférieur
je vous rappelle pas de doute
j'ai un côté devant la pierre des bêtes
un énorme les lèvres gigantesque
vous savez je lui ai répété ces mots
tellement de fois que je suis fier que
doit les connaître par coeur maintenant
[Musique]
et l'éclopé tu sais à quoi je peux
prouver que dit la vérité
l'odeur la personne à côté de moi et
sent la merde et c'est normal parce
qu'il est occupé à laver la chiasse de
notre hui et grâce à qui il a eu cette
promotion et la grâce à moi vas-y
l'éclopé pas peur je te jure tu peux le
sentir à quelques mètres qui la
rapproche toi mcdermott
n'aie pas peur mais c'est
oui
asie
dassin
[Musique]
m
c
alors
et
oui mais
en
[Musique]
si je devais tuer tous les mecs qui
schlague on s'en sortirait pas non et
était pas mal son plan dommage que j'ai
entendu ces chaînes de [ __ ] gling
gling gling gling allait bien la
bienvenue chez moi ma petite cuisine ma
petite femme
et voilà tu peux être installée
[Musique]